eddie is a well-connected farmer stored
in his phone is all the data he needs
about his head of cows all made possible
by a unique identification number fitted
to the cow's ears and once fitted it
stays with the cow all their life but
this is just a number an upgrade is in
the works but you could soon see 87
million cows across europe fitted with
electronic tags information such as
their age breed and sex would be stored
on the chip instead of on databases and
offices like this one in belgium
electronics
it's taking some three years for the new
legislation to get off the ground but
for the author of the report it's an
important step towards better food
safety and traceability especially in
the event
so one device for all but will this all
for one and one for all approach work if
the system is voluntary that is
ridiculous and what has been negotiated
after a week commission proposal in the
parliament in the trilogs is so weak
that one cannot even say with high up
head that that is a success for
consumers it is not it's bad and some
cattle farmers and especially small
farmers are already questioning the
potential cost of electronic tagging
so it could be that even if the
legislation is pushed through many
farmers may opt out